right so i'm trying to build up the
timeline of my head so you're in source
forever how long were you
i was there for damn uh let's see i was
an
intern first which was 2012. i was a
actual host in 2014. i was there for
two years but it no i was there for
three years but it felt like
much longer yeah well it sounds like a
really important part of like the career
absolutely yeah and i also did a lot of
things with them
afterwards so kind of really did feel
much longer
yeah yeah yeah and so the reason why you
left is obviously because it did just
get
wiped uh well i left before that
yeah so yeah this is such a strange
thing i never talked about it before but
um my everything went into our gaming
channel
me and stephen septics and we were doing
so well and then they canceled it anyway
and i was so heartbroken and when they
say they
just said that there was no budget for
it which is such a i know it's a let's
play
like why like they buy the game on steam
yeah i know it's crazy we don't have ten
dollars for the steam game yeah but
i must say septic did spend over two
grand on cs go cases once
uh using the company card and we wrote
it off and it was like okay
it's that's their fault they should have
just told us that that's hilarious
that is such an epic movie yeah i know
it yeah and he got like the
[ __ ] butterfly knife
so like whatever but anyway
well yeah they said there's no budget
and there's like a lot of like
production reasons
behind it but um then because the
whole channel was dissolved and i was
a og like host for that term for that
time
they brought me back into sourcefed nerd
and sourcefed proper
instead of like outright laying me off
but they laid off
septic and i was like so weird
about that but i also needed money to
survive in every day so there was not
much i could do about it
and then when i left septic got hired
again
as a as like a or like a source fed
proper member i know i know so strange
yeah
and that's when i kind of realized
something was super super wrong with the
entirety of the company not that there's
anything wrong with steve but you know
the fact that
letting someone go and then bringing
them back in later is really bizarre
and then like oh it almost felt like
they were like trying to separate
us so that we wouldn't try something on
our own
but yeah that was like a major thing
also you know discovery like owned our
face and soul
for x amount of years according to our
contract because we were like oh god
yeah so that was also i'm suspecting
that was also why
they maybe wanted to keep us separate so
that our faces wouldn't be together on
another thing that we created right
right
because you and steve i guess created
like a brand almost created like a brand
for your arm yeah yeah
yeah i ended up like kind of doing that
which was amazing but also i do think
that that probably was dangerous for the
company and for the shareholders maybe
but
because the thing about you know uh big
companies hiring youtubers to do videos
for the company
is that the audience end up being loyal
to the host and the personality because
they're
they're the heart and soul of the show
so even if they leave
you've already created a brand for
yourself right right and
yeah i mean it's it [ __ ] is pretty
scummy that you know yeah
yeah stuff like that has you know
happens it sucks like now having been in
the industry in many different ways like
as an independent youtuber as somebody
that's hired by bigger companies like
it's entertainment media um new media
old media it kind of can't
be helped right now i think it's
starting to improve or maybe change
in a way that's beneficial to
independent creators especially with
youtube and twitch and everything like
that but
it's still very difficult like the
biggest chunk of money that's solid
is definitely still in the hands of
bigger companies so
yeah that does definitely kind of sway
yeah what i wanted to know is
you've you've obviously you got involved
in this by being an intern for
philly d is that the job that you wanted
like did you want to work in youtube
um i was a fan and i was just watching
him and i was
uh watching some of sourcefed and i was
what was i doing oh yeah i was an
apprentice pastry chef in new jersey
i know i know afterwards graduated from
is that what you wanted to do though
um i this is so weird i knew i was good
at it
sounds so pretentious i don't want it to
be but i knew i was good at
it i mean you became an apprentice right
so i guess it makes sense
just own it right now because i was
[ __ ] amazing i was like really good
at it
i was making wedding cakes and i
actually made uh japan airlines first
class desserts for a year yeah that was
me
yeah she was pretty [ __ ] good at it
yeah jesus christ
so i was doing that and but i didn't
like it because you have to go to work
at
one no 2 a.m right and then you're out
at like
like 12 1 p.m but it's i don't know like
i i got kind of depressed i think not
not like actually depressed but i was
not
well that doesn't really leave you much
time to do anything you need to sleep
right so you try to sleep during the day
but that's i don't know like i
never want to do stuff yeah i was
younger and i was like i want to like
party and play and do all these things
so
i don't think it was just it made a lot
of sense for me at the time and
uh then my now husband but then
roommate slash boyfriend and i were like
we like let's just do something crazy
and we moved to la
and i just ha we actually auditioned
together
i got it he did it and it kind of
mesmerized me as a fan being able to be
on the opposite side of it and being the
intern that like researches stuff
and i do believe that there was a lot of
like political stuff going on at the
time so i was also
re-educated which was really interesting
for me having having been out of
college already i was like oh this is so
much fun there's so much to learn and
then phil wanted me
to me to be on camera and i was like no
way
like you want me to bring in these sexy
girls
i thought you never asked yeah i was
here to do that
that was my plan wow
yeah so i i really started as a fan for
lack of a better term i wasn't like an
obsessive fan but there wasn't
i mean i don't think he would have hired
you if you were an obsessive yeah he
would have like smelled it right
[Laughter]
he smelled the